veamos ahora el problema número 27 si es
igual la raíz cuadrada de menos 1 cuarto
es 4 y por 6 y bueno las
multiplicaciones son asociativas por lo
que podemos intercambiar términos aquí y
reescribir esto como 4 por 6 por y por i
que esto es igual al 4 por 6 24 y por iu
y cuadrada y cuadrada pero ya que nos
dicen que es igual a raíz cuadrada de
menos 1 y cuadrada va a ser igual a
menos 1 esto es lo mismo que tener 24 x
menos uno que es lo mismo que tener
menos 24 que es mi opción ser
veamos el siguiente problema el número
28 cuál es la forma equivalente de 2
entre 3 más y muchas veces a la gente no
les gusta tener números complejos en el
denominador los números complejos son
aquellos que tienen una parte real y
otra parte imaginaria en este caso
podemos multiplicar esto por su
conjugado que suena muy sofisticado pero
simplemente es tomar el opuesto de la
parte imaginaria
recuerden que la única forma de
multiplicar algo por una fracción sin
cambiarla es multiplicar el numerador y
el denominador por lo mismo es decir si
yo aquí tengo 2 entre 3 más y el
multiplicar esto por su conjugado tanto
en el numerador como el denominador base
es multiplicar esto por 3 - sí
entre 3 - y esto es un 1 porque es la
misma cantidad entre la misma cantidad
así no estoy afectando este valor pero
lo que me ayuda es que al multiplicar
esto estas y esos números imaginarios se
van a ir el conjugado es tener nada más
el signo contrario
en la parte imaginaria del número eso es
solamente de lo que se trata
vamos a hacer esta operación esto es
igual no voy a poner en otro color
simplemente para que se vea más alegre 2
x 3 menos y 6 -2 y
/
3 x 3 93 por menos si es menos 3 sí
ahora y por tres es igual a más 3
y por menos si es menos y cuadrada menos
y cuadrada
vamos a simplificar esto vemos que estos
dos elementos se van a ir menos 3 y 3 y
se van me queda aquí abajo 9 menos
cuadrada sabemos que es raíz de menos 1
raíces menos 1 al cuadrado me va a
quedar menos 1 esto por menos 1 y lo de
arriba queda igual 6 menos 12
la diferencia es que ahora el número
complejo me quedo arriba y no abajo
esto menos por menos es más nueve más
uno es igual a 10 6 menos 2 y entre 10
eso todavía lo puedo simplificar más
porque tanto el numerador como el
denominador puedo dividirlo entre 26
entre 2 estrés
2 entre 2 1
es entre 2 y 5 que es la opción b
muy bien ok entonces el siguiente
problema es el 29 3 más y por 3 menos y
pues que cree en esto o qué casualidad
esto de aquí es lo mismo que tenemos acá
3 más y por 3 menos y que es lo que
desarrollamos aquí en el denominador de
todo esto 3 por 3 93 por menos si es
menos 3 sí y por 3 es 3i y por menos si
es menos y cuadrada estos se cancelan
nos quedan 9 y cuadrar es menos uno
menos por menos es más 9 +1 es 10 así
que esto es igual a 10 uy qué cosa tan
rápida esta es nuestra opción b vaya qué
problemas tan bonitos estos que se
resuelven inmediatamente muy bien ahora
veamos el problema número 30
si es igual a raíz de menos 1 y a y b
son números reales diferentes de 0 que
es uno entre a más ve por aquí parece
que quieren que quitemos el número
complejo del denominador así que debemos
multiplicar por el conjugado entre
conjugado si yo tengo vamos a poner en
un color azul bonito uno entre además b
jamás vi
lo multiplicó por el conjugado entre el
conjugado quedamos que conjugado es ese
número pero con el signo contrario en la
parte del número imaginaria
es a menos b por i
/ a
- por y hacemos de esta operación nos
queda 1 por esto me voy a quedar a menos
en el numerador y el denominador es a
por a a cuadrada
por menos ve y es menos a mí
b y por a es más puedo poner el orden de
los factores aquí no importa la
multiplicación esa asociativa la pongo a
b
y ve y por menos 20 es menos b y al
cuadrado
al cuadrado vamos a simplificar el
denominador estos menos sabe más a b y
se van me queda a cuadrada menos
b x al cuadrado es igual a menos b
cuadrada x y al cuadrado
el numerador me queda igual a menos
porque y esto el cuadrado que damos que
si es raíz de menos 1 y cuadrada va a
ser igual a menos 1 está es igual a
cuadrada menos b cuadrada por menos 1
número 2 se mantiene igual a menos b
y esto es igual a menos por menos es más
es igual a menos 20 entre a cuadrada más
b
sin la y ya lo quitamos y esta es mi ve
al cuadrado ya se les olvidando b al
cuadrado esta es mi opción b bien veamos
el último problema de este vídeo que es
el número 31 una de las soluciones a la
ecuación x cuadrada más 2 x más 2 igual
a cero
es cuando vemos una ecuación como esta
nos debemos preguntar qué par de números
al sumarlos nos dan 2 y al
multiplicarlos nos dan 2 ésta es una
difícil vamos a usar la ecuación
cuadrática el formato de la ecuación
cuadrática que es uno muy muy muy común
casi cada escuela y en cada país tiene
un nombre muy familiar para relacionarlo
en mi escuela en particular le decían
que esta es la fórmula de las
quesadillas porque hasta el que vende
quesadillas la sabe es
x cuadrada más bx más e igual a cero si
yo tengo una ecuación cuadrática de esta
forma la solución los posibles valores
de x van a ser igual a menos b
- la raíz cuadrada de be cuadrada de
cuadrada menos 4 a c
todo esto entre 2
ahora vamos a sustituir cuál sería en
esta ecuación cuál sería el valor de a
sería igual a 1 b esta vez sería igual a
dos veces igualados y se es igual a 2 es
igual a 2 vamos a sustituir esto en este
formato de la ecuación x es igual a
menos b
2 - 2 + menos raíz cuadrada de b
cuadrada b queremos que es 2 al cuadrado
menos 4 x a a es 162
la raíz cuadrada de esto entre 2 y 2 por
simplifiquemos esto es igual a menos 2 +
menos raíz cuadrada 2 al cuadrado es 4
menos 4 por unos 4 por 2 828 avales aquí
quedó algo interesante entre 2
sigamos simplificando 4 - 8 va a ser
menos 4 me queda aquí menos dos más
menos raíz cuadrada de menos 4
entre dos esto yo puedo decir que es
igual
- dos más menos raíz cuadrada de cuatro
por menos uno es lo mismo que lo que
tengo acá
y sabemos que la raíz de menos 1 es y
esto es lo mismo que tener menos 2 más
menos la raíz de cuatro es 2 raíz de
menos 1 es el número imaginario entre 2
y para terminar de simplificar esto
vemos que estos dos los puedo dividir
entre dos menos 2 entre 2 me quedan que
es igual a menos 1 más menos 2 y entre 2
me queda que es mi opción c es decir que
esto la respuesta a los algunas de las
soluciones a la ecuación es cuando x
es igual a menos 1 más
cuando x es igual a menos 1 - y
cualquiera de las dos nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo